foreign
as you know it is under attack and it's
more fragile than you might think
nerdia screechier days of the net the
possibilities seemed endless
information wants to be free said the
web 1.0 Pioneers they envisioned a free
internet where countless independent
nodes would sustain a worldwide system
of instant communication entirely
decentralized and therefore immune to
central control or sabotage
cuts it today and I think they got it
about half right
so much for independent it now seems
like the internet and its infrastructure
are owned by the same free American
dudes in a world of Mega platforms
attention-sapping algorithms and mass
surveillance we aren't wondering if
information is free we're wondering if
we are
now with all the Doom and Gloom aside I
should say I love the Internet it's
where I spend most of my time the best
thing about my pandemic has been
watching the rest of you get reduced to
my level it's Excel it's accelerated the
digital world's invasion of the material
one that meeting that could have been an
email is now an email malls are being
shut by search bars fortnite tournaments
are filling national stadiums and jpegs
are selling for the price of a da Vinci
whatever happens next we're all going to
be spending more time online so how do
we protect what makes it great and
change what makes it terrifying
well first of all I think we need an
update internet access is no longer a
luxury it is a necessity for economic
and individual development for
developing countries increased access is
a pathway out of poverty and enables
smoother access to essential services
like education and Healthcare
as millions in the global South have
logged on the way the world accesses the
internet has completely changed in 2011
mobile internet use accounted for just
five percent of total traffic today it
sits comfortably at 56 percent
cheap phones and 4G have made the
internet truly Global but it also means
that most of us only access it through a
handful of applications
the internet is in all of your pockets
and this is a TED talk so it's probably
on most of your wrists not mine I've got
a calculator
keeps me humble
that's where we access it but we
wouldn't be able to if it weren't for
unassuming securely guarded buildings
like this one
internet exchange points where bandwidth
is actually produced if these places
cease to operate then the internet is
down and not even the sweatiest guy in
your it Department can do anything about
it
in 2011 the Egyptian government shut
down one of the country's two main
Exchange points the Ramses Exchange in
Cairo
the internet was being used to organize
protests as users were galvanized by
sharing videos of ongoing violence in
real time
for days only a few government
Ministries and the stock market were
connected to the internet it was a
threat to the crumbling regime and when
the government did fall the internet got
the Lion's Share of the credit
protests were organized with
out-appointed leaders and with
unprecedented speed and this is what the
internet does that no other technology
has ever come close to achieving
decentralized Mass organization
since then though regimes have gotten a
lot better at harnessing the internet's
power for themselves in 2019 both Iran
and Iraq faced potentially destabilizing
protest movements and both governments
reacted by pulling the national router
these blackouts though are costly Iraq's
11-day shutdown was estimated to cost
their economy over 2 billion dollars
Iran's only lasted eight days but the
communication blackout was used to
imprison organizers and murder
protesters in their hundreds
video of violence made its way online
once access was restored but by then the
protest movement had lost all momentum
this year the front line fight for the
free internet has been in Myanmar
the military Junta seized power in
February and enacted nightly internet
shutdowns to hinder protest and hide
human rights abuses
social media was banned for months but
activists have been successfully
skirting restrictions using vpns to
access restricted services and to
document state violence
this is Guerrilla cyber warfare in
action and it has real-world casualties
mobile phones might be empowering the
resistance but they are also
facilitating data-driven Mass
surveillance
use the wrong platform and the
government can monitor your private
messages and automatically delete them
before they reach their intended
recipient
to me this is like halfway between the
government censoring your mail
and your thoughts
but it's not hopeless
just before the Junta took over
their arrival was documented in this
viral video by a fitness influencer
example
guys the junta's top brass arriving in
the background to depose the
democratically elected leader
now I love this video it simultaneously
absurd and tragic which I feel like are
the twin moods of the internet at the
moment
but it also shows that even when the
entire National infrastructure of the
internet is controlled by a repressive
regime
information still wants to be free
in the west though some of us are
worried the information has gotten a bit
too free in some cases fact-free
disinformation and misinformation on
social media are testing the boundaries
of free speech the World Health
Organization has called the pandemic an
infodemic with their official updates
sharing a timeline with posts telling
you to cure coronavirus by drinking
bleach
in the UK a conspiracy theory linking 5G
to coronavirus spread so quickly that it
led to over 30 arson attacks on South
Towers in March 2020 alone
absurd tragic once again but it's easy
to see there's a problem
combating disinformation is tricky when
Mega platforms have become so enormous
that they're nearly impossible to
effectively moderate
when Facebook attempted to use machine
learning to identify and remove
dangerous posts it often couldn't tell
the difference between government
guidance and posts meant to mimic it
imperfect machines ultimately create
imperfect machines
so this is a very human problem and it
obviously outdates the internet there's
always been demand for disinformation
it's based on what people want to
believe
and where there is demand there is
opportunity to supply
Facebook themselves will tell you that
most disinformation on their platform is
financially incentivized
malicious actors who own small websites
crammed with ads who will pay to
advertise on Facebook first to get the
ball rolling
platforms might not be able to moderate
everything we say and I don't think they
should but they are more than capable of
disrupting and regulating who pays them
of course Mega platforms resist any
regulation of their advertising because
it's where they make most of their money
we all know they aren't selling us a
service they're selling access to our
eyeballs
there's now a widespread distrust of the
unregulated internet
in the UK there has been popular public
campaigns and subsequent government
proposals to connect social media
accounts to government-issued
identification getting rid of the
anonymity and holding people accountable
for all the naughty things they say
online
this is well-meaning but it's a [__]
terrible idea marginalized groups and
political dissidents rely on anonymity
to protect their free speech and having
your government ID connected to your
social media account would leave you
extremely vulnerable to phishing scams
and identity theft
I don't share my name online or anywhere
publicly not because I'm shy but because
I'm just curious to see how long I can
keep it up
gaining notoriety but retaining
anonymity is a unique privilege of the
information age so why not take
advantage of it
the internet is difficult to tame
because it was built that way
this is John postal a man who once held
the unofficial title of God of the
internet here he is posing in posing in
front of a hand-drawn map a bit in 1998
the US government had contracted John to
run the root authority of the domain
name system the closest thing the
internet infrastructure has to the top
of its hierarchy
basically when you type in twitter.com
or
paymytaxes.gov the root Authority is
what makes sure you get there
that's an oversimplification but what
you need to understand is that whoever
controls the root Authority controls
access to every website and
theoretically could delete all of them
so when the US government asked John to
hand control over he said no
and this one act of resistance would
lead to the creation of I can an
international multi-stakeholder group
that ensures the global internet can't
be controlled by a single company or
government
naturally some governments have resisted
this
notably the Chinese government have been
advocating for what they call internet
sovereignty since 2013. this is the idea
that each country has the right to
control a separate version of the
internet within their own borders of
course China's internet has worked this
way for decades but it's increasingly an
attractive option to others Iran booted
up their own version in 2018 and Russia
are quietly testing theirs out
and these National firewalls are used to
restrict unwanted information but their
main priority is to crush organization
that happens outside of a party
political structure
and frankly if it is disinformation that
we're worried about governments are the
last group we should trust with
regulating it
in 2018 Facebook CEO Cheryl Sandberg
claimed that the company deleted over
1.3 billion fake accounts in just six
months
a few hundred million of them were
probably cooked up here in the Old Saint
Petersburg Office of the internet
research agency a private company
owned by a close friend of Vladimir
Putin and a state-funded Troll Army
their job is to spread disinformation
and so Discord online with a phantom RB
of puppet accounts and conspiracy
theories
that job isn't to bolster the argument
of one side but to inflame debate and
make all signs look equally ridiculous
but this nihilistic genre of propaganda
is incredibly weak when it's confronted
with the sincerity of Outsiders
that's why I think Alexi navalny is the
most interesting person on the internet
today
if you don't know who he is he's a lot
of things a dissident lawyer criminal
and YouTuber who took on the Russian
government his video on Putin's Palace
got 120 million views which inspires
professional ore and jealousy in me and
aside from some high budget drone shots
there is very little new information in
this video
it's a compilation of previously
available sources sometimes decades-old
information
but unlike these old sources this video
reached 25 million people in 24 hours
and delivered this information in an
exciting hilarious and inclusive way
after a surviving assassination attempt
and being sentenced to a penal colony
navalny is still leading resistance
online
the Kremlin have duly blocked
access to this video
and have blocked access to Smart boating
websites which navalny has been
propagating we might be frightened of
Mega platforms but they are empowering
individuals and giving Outsiders an
audience that dwarfs the one offered by
Legacy Media establishments that
dominated the information market during
the last century
and I know it feels like we're spending
our lives flicking between the same four
apps and that's because we are around 80
percent of internet traffic is captured
by only a handful of companies and we're
spending progressively more time with
them
thanks to lockdown and homeworking
internet use in the UK doubled in just
one year
and all of those Netflix binges are
putting a strain on the internet's
infrastructure
this is a hyperscale data center there's
around 600 of them worldwide and over
half of them are owned by either Amazon
Microsoft Google or Apple
the number of these computer cabinet
labyrinths has doubled in the last five
years to keep up with our ever
increasing demand and this is upset
internet service providers who claim
that these bandwidth hogging companies
aren't paying their fair share
and maybe they aren't and while I do
think it is concerning that so few
companies control so much of the
internet
I don't think their reign is assured
internal projections at Facebook show
that teenagers are abandoning their
platform in their droves so much so that
their American user base could decrease
by up to 45 in two years
I'm not saying that the problem will
solve itself these platforms are
powerful but only in proportion to the
time and attention that we give them
it's easy to forget that the internet is
still in its infancy and new competitors
are gathering in every corner
thank you
then there are competitors like the
super apps and these apps are
interesting
they're mobile only mostly an Asian
phenomenon so far they are applications
that position themselves as a One-Stop
shop for all your internet-based needs
Singapore has grab Indonesia has go-to
but by far the most popular is China's
WeChat
with over 1.3 billion active daily users
WeChat has integrated itself into the
fabric of normal social life in China
it's your driver's license your debit
card and your phone it's where you pay
your landlord book flights hotels and
doctors appointments
it has supercharged China's Journey
towards a cashless Society replacing
coins with QR codes with even the
homeless Force to upgrade
and it is a brilliant tool it has
brought older generations and the
industrial working class online and
giving them easier access to essential
services
but it also conveniently bundles up all
of your personal data private messages
and physical whereabouts for a
government with backdoor access
the surveillance enabled by these super
apps is threatening to turn privacy into
a relic of the 20th century
because when there's only one platform
there's nowhere left to hide
the internet was built to be plural to
exist nowhere in particular and to be
accessible everywhere
internet culture is global culture
arguably the first ever instance of it
and we must ensure that everyone has
equal access
no one in this room knows what the
internet will look like in 10 50 or 100
years but we can be damn sure it will be
here
it's the greatest invention of all of
our lifetimes and we must ensure that it
reflects the best of us
it must be open
inquiring
cooperative
and suspicious of authority
thank you
[Applause]